I'm pretty certain that we're gonna lose
the actual ice shelf itself and parts
the West Antarctic Ice Sheet at some
point in the future it'll turn into
water but it's weird that water goes and
how much of it turns actually into sea
level that's the big question right 16
metres requires a whole reorganization
of how we live in our civilization
because you write off some of the most
populated parts the world you know
downtown London or monkeys that's gone
in order to study the ice shelves
geological history they need to find
sediment on the sea floor beneath it so
they can sample it as part of the
project in future years I mean we can
throw the stream around now and then we
just want to make sure that this is the
right place you know we've just dragged
all this equipment out yet the immediate
goal of just see the seafloor make sure
it's there and that it's flat and smooth
and if there aren't big rocks in the way
for the signs well this is a big deal
you know we're talking about megabucks
for us a lot of time a lot of effort
from a lot of people this is a lot
riding on it to determine if they're in
the right spot the team will launch a
hydraulically driven 500-pound weight
called the thumper at the ice and use
the reflected sound heard by 96
geological microphones to create a
picture of what they can't see basically
be slicing through the ice shelf through
the ocean and into the seafloor we turn
that slice on a site and then weensy the
different layers inside the ocean so we
don't have a short circuit right exactly
so our goal is to actually get that
picture of what's underneath the ice
shelf we hope that our research will
impact those people they decide right
climate change this is a problem now
there's carbon dioxide is gonna kill the
ice it's gonna melt it and we're gonna
be in trouble we've been building
equipment for six months and we're just
really excited to actually get into it
we didn't trigger a check again that's
not good as soon as the wave drops it
hits a switch and it triggers the system
it basically triggers the microphones to
start listening for some reason it's not
doing it when the way it goes down but
when the weight goes up so we're just
trying to sort of figure out why it's
doing that and trigger again if the
thumper and geophones are even
milliseconds out of sync
the results are worthless I think I can
see the problem there sled got too many
links at the back so now it's not Center
properly I think we need to pull it
backwards slightly all of our systems
have come from different areas around
the globe so I am geophone streamer came
from Germany our computer system and the
geodes they came from the states so it
is a little bit nerve-wracking to see
whether all those components do interact
and whether they work in an Antarctic
environment
okay triggers yeah that's good do you
get move up if our team is unsuccessful
for finding a proper location then it is
basically the end of that aspect of the
program so I think we are a little bit
worried